they pull a knife you pull a gun he
sends one of yours to the hospital you
send one of his to the morgue that's the
chicago way those words showed us that
in a world ruled by crime and corruption
where might makes right you need a
virtuous man willing to do extraordinary
things in order to get the job done
during 1920s chicago notorious mobster
al capone had a strangle hold on the
city if you were smart you accepted his
bribes and looked the other way
alternatively you could attempt to bring
him down if he had a death wish so what
do you do in the situation where the
cancer of the mob has infested every
facet of the local authority from
politicians to judges to cops well you
bring an elliot ness in his squad of
trusty sidekicks known as the
untouchables the name comes from the
fact that nes and his men were
impervious to all persuasion attempts
from the other side of the law neither
bribes nor threats nor violence got in
the way of them doing their job and
finally putting al capone behind bars
where he belonged
[Music]
elias was born in chicago illinois on
april the 19th 1903 the youngest of five
children to peter nair sunema king to
immigrants from norway who owned and
operated a bakery in chicago elliott was
much younger than his siblings there was
a 10-year gap between him and the second
youngest member of the ness family
therefore he grew up playing with his
nieces and nephews rather than his
brothers and sisters from a young age
elliott showed an interest in detective
stories particularly the ones featuring
sherlock holmes at school he always did
well graduating from wenger high school
in the top third of his class afterwards
ness enrolled at the university of
chicago where he studied political
science and business administration
earning his bachelor's degree in 1925.
now that he was finished with his
studies elliot ness needed a job
initially he worked as an investigator
for the retail credit company collecting
background information on potential
clients he paid the bills but it didn't
really get the heart rate up ness wanted
something more exciting and fortunately
for him one of his brothers-in-law was
alexander jamie a prohibition agent who
would later go on to become the head of
the fbi's chicago department jaime
recommended that ness made the switch to
law enforcement so the latter went back
to college for some postgraduate studies
in criminology and found a new job with
the treasury department in 1927. a year
later his brother-in-law secured a
position for ness as a federal agent
with the prohibition bureau country's
popular belief eliot ness was never an
fbi agent nor was he an agent with the
fbi's precursor the bureau of
investigations or boi led by j edgar
hoover the confusion stems from the fact
that during its 13-year existence the
bureau of prohibition was under the
umbrella of multiple government
departments including the irs the
treasury department and the justice
department in 1933 president roosevelt
wanted the two bureaus to combine into a
single investigation unit under the
purview of the justice department hoover
however was strongly against the idea
not wanting to mix his trusted 300 or so
boi agents with the over 1 200
prohibition officers who were unknown to
him ultimately he persuaded the
president who placed hoover in charge of
both agencies but kept them as separate
entities so elianes did work as a
federal agent for j edgar hoover for a
while just not in the fbi nest then took
a different job in cleveland six weeks
later and left the bureau which got
disbanded entirely a few months later
once prohibition was repealed
[Music]
before all of that happened though there
was one case that defined elliot ness's
career one case that cemented his
reputation of being untouchable the
biggest problem with prohibition was
that there was a lot of money to be made
in bootlegging a lot of money think of a
figure and then triple it it's that kind
of money with that kind of money getting
spread around it wasn't really
surprising that many prohibition agents
fell into temptation and took bribes to
look the other way that was one of the
main reasons why the bureau kept getting
moved from one department to another an
attempt to quell the rampant corruption
that had taken hold of it at every level
one of the many men who made a fortune
during prohibition was a chicago
gangster you're probably familiar with
al capone during the late 1920s he was
one of the biggest bootleggers in the
country but he was also someone who
didn't shy away from conflict his
chicago outfit was embroiled in a bitter
and violent feud with the irish north
side gang led by bugs moran as both
organizations fought to control
organized crime in the city this rivalry
ended in a bloody ferocious and
conclusive manner on february 14 1929
the day of the infamous valentine's day
massacre that crippled the north side
gang and left it a shell of its former
self but even during a time of gang
warfare where deadly shootouts were
common such a brutal event could not be
ignored by the authorities al capone
became the number one target of all law
enforcement agencies in the country
however he had the muscle and the money
to make most agents think twice about
dealing with him so where would they
find someone who would be impervious to
capone's threats and bribes and willing
to take him on never mind the violent
crimes it would have been almost
impossible to gather enough evidence for
a conviction on any of those charges if
they wanted to get al capone there were
two avenues to pursue his finances and
his bootlegging a task force from the
special intelligence unit or sru led by
el mariari of the irs was set to tackle
the first one as for the second that
task fell to eliot ness we're not
entirely sure what made the government
think that ness was the right man for
the job after all he had only been a
prohibition agent for a few years by
that point it's usually believed that
his brother-in-law got in the interview
but ness persuaded the man in charge
chicago attorney george eq johnson that
he should be the one leading the squad
whatever he did or said during that
interview we don't know but by the end
of 1913 ness was put in charge of a
small team of a dozen or so prohibition
agents whose goal was to damage capone's
bootlegging operations as much as
possible and collect whatever evidence
they found related to his illicit income
elianes was allowed to choose his own
men for this operation after all
corruption was one of the biggest
obstacles that prevented honest cops
from doing their work so nest needed to
trust the men on his team he selected 10
agents ness was the head of the squad
and then there was u.s attorney general
william frolick who served as his
immediate supervisor they were the
original untouchable dozen but we should
point out that several other agents were
added along the way and some of the
original ones left before the
investigation was over and some were
kicked off the squad because they
weren't quite as untouchable as one
might expect of the untouchables plus
occasionally ns worked with outside
agents when it came to some of the
larger raids as well as local police so
the untouchables weren't this renegade
lone wolf unit despite the reputation it
developed in the decades that followed
[Music]
according to eliot nurse's own account
their operations started by staking out
known speakeasies they could have busted
down the doors raided the joints and
arrested the pie-eyed patrons but they
weren't interested in a few small drunk
fish they wanted the big fish who were
making and selling the booze so they sat
and they waited knowing that someone
would come and pick up the empty beer
barrels and take them to get refilled
eventually a truck arrived and picked up
the barrels two of nes's men jim sealy
and joe leeson tailed it to a factory
which they hoped would be an illegal
brewery so they could put it under
24-hour guard to their disappointment
they discovered the capone's operation
was not only bigger but also more
complex than they could ever have
imagined the factory was being used
solely to steam clean the barrels there
wasn't a drop of hooch inside but this
time when the truck left it was
accompanied by two gangsters in a ford
coupe
both packing tommy guns so the lead
still looked promising celie and leeson
stayed on its tail but still no luck the
truck now pulled into a large garage
where it stayed for a few days in order
to cool off undeterred the agents
watched and waited unless capone had
access to teleportation technology at
some point someone somewhere had to
physically take the barrels fill them
with beer and put them inside the truck
and the untouchables wanted to be there
when they did after three or four nights
of vigil they had paid her the truck
left the garage and drove to a
nondescript building about a block and a
half away once again the agents placed
it on a 24-hour watch they saw two
trucks with barrels enter followed by a
huge tank truck 40 minutes later the
trucks departed the building clearly
laid him with a much heavier load ness
had found what he was looking for and it
was now time for a raid the first
untouchables raid the first of many took
place on the morning of march the 11th
ness had a team of 15. there was the
main squad consisting of himself a local
prohibition agent and his three heavy
hitters bill garner a 240-pound native
american made of solid muscle ernest
seeger a former prison guard at
sing-sing and lal chapman a six foot one
former football tackle at colgate
university they were accompanied by 10
uniformed cops no prisoners had ever
been taken in a raid on one of capone's
breweries we don't mean that they were
gunned down or anything like that but
that they always managed to escape
whether this was due to poor planning
incompetence corruption or a nice little
mix of all three nest didn't know and he
didn't care because he intended to
change that he had a big heavy truck
fitted with a giant steel bumper on the
front ness wanted to crash that thing
right through the doors of the brewery
so that no vehicles could pass by it and
he did his squad of five loaded up the
truck and rammed straight into the
building catching everyone inside
completely unaware two police cars
followed close by while the rest of the
cops gathered on the roof to make sure
that nobody got out that way the results
were solid the raid resulted in the
capture of five men including al
capone's brewmaster steve ceviboda
someone that ness would get very
familiar with in subsequent raids they
also found seven 320 gallon vats which
were capable of producing a hundred
barrels of beer per day once the fun
stuff was over it was lyle chapman's
time to shine described by elliot ness
as his pencil detective chapman went
through the records to see if he could
find anything that tied it to capone the
mobster was careful but not that careful
and on that occasion chapman managed to
connect one of the delivery trucks to
him overall it was a nice start but a
lot more would be needed in order to put
a serious dent in capote's bootlegging
operations so that in mind the raids
continued breweries and distilleries
were stormed trucks were seized
equipment was confiscated or destroyed
and thousands upon thousands of gallons
of alcohol were poured down the train
and yes that last one makes us a little
sad too sometimes the raids turned up
nothing with obvious signs that the
breweries had been emptied in a hurry
nesslater claimed that capone had paid
anyone 500 no question to ask if they
came forward with a good tip that one of
his breweries was about to get raided
but even the dry holes were costly for
the mob due to the sudden interruptions
and the delays add to that the losses
from successful raids plus the attorney
fees and the bail money for guys who got
pinched and the untouchables were
starting to cut pretty deep into
capone's bottom line
[Music]
the press of course ate all of this up
the story of an incorruptable squad of
agents tackling the biggest mob in
chicago was enticing enough but then it
was often accompanied by thrilling
images of groups storming into breweries
in their trucks bursting down doors and
walking out with thousands of gallons of
illegal hooch there is one apocryphal
story which said that early on eliot
ness taunted al capone by parading his
confiscated trucks and beer in front of
the lexington hotel where the mob boss
had his headquarters but if he did no
records of this event exist there is
another that said one of capone's
henchmen approached net and informed him
that there would be two thousand dollars
on his desk every week if he would stop
his raids two thousand dollars is about
thirty seven thousand dollars in today's
money and it was just a few hundred
bucks less than the starting yearly
salary for a prohibition agent so it was
quite a chunk of change but of course
eliot ness refused any officer bribery
prompting one of the chicago newsmen to
come up with an iconic name for his
squad the untouchables strangely enough
there was little violence involved in
nes's operation you'd think that al
capone wouldn't be the kind of guy that
you could bilk out of millions of
dollars and just walk away unscathed but
that's pretty much what happened
elianess received some threats by phone
and letter had his car stolen and was
once driven off the road by a truck
convoy but that was about it quite tame
by mob's standards maybe even capone was
reticent of declaring open season on
federal agents fearing the response that
that would prompt anyway following
months of raids the untouchables not
only seriously crippled bootlegging in
chicago but also amassed evidence for up
to 5 000 violations of the volstead act
aka the national prohibition act it was
time to take this case home and put
capone behind bars
right
well no not quite ness's higher ups were
hesitant to prosecute the mobster
because they knew that prohibition was
wildly unpopular just because alcohol
became illegal didn't mean that people
magically stopped wanting to get
hammered if anything the one thing
prohibition did was to show just how
much people were willing to go through
just for a glass of that sweet sweet
intoxicating nectar even when that
nectar was dangerous rock gut with that
in mind prosecutors feared that they
might not secure a conviction on
bootlegging charges alone consequently
it was up to the siu to save the day the
other task force that went after
capone's financial records they brought
charges of income tax evasion and in
october 1931 capone was found guilty and
sentenced to 11 years in prison although
the untouchables were essential in
debilitating the chicago outfit the sru
were the unsung heroes of this tale
unfortunately for them the newspapers
chased the better story and busting down
doors made for some more exciting copy
than doing thorough paperwork fair or
not as the face of crime fighting in
chicago eliot ness garnered the lion's
share of the praise and was promoted to
chief investigator for the prohibition
bureau in chicago and contrary to
popular belief his raids continued even
after capone was behind bars since his
operations were still going on although
not as strong as before ness's last big
raid in chicago occurred on the 23rd of
june 1933 and he went out with a bang he
confiscated the largest still in the
city capable of distilling 5 000 gallons
a day truth be told the untouchables
could have probably continued carrying
out raids ad infinitum given the money
involved in bootlegging there would
always have been someone willing to risk
it ultimately the only way to eliminate
bootlegging was to eliminate the need
for it by ending prohibition that was
what happened in december 1933 thus
making the untouchables redundant as far
as elliot ness was concerned he was
moved around for a bit after chicago he
worked in cincinnati for a spell in 1934
before being transferred to cleveland
that same year but ness was the golden
boy
and he knew it given how much positive
publicity he received for being
untouchable he could find a much better
job so in 1935 he resigned as a federal
agent a few months later the mayor of
cleveland named elliot ness as the new
safety director of the city giving him
authority over both the police and the
fire department his goals were to reform
the police department improve traffic
safety and lower the crime rates by
targeting drugs gambling and corruption
however he had no idea that he had just
signed up to go up against another
murderous foe like al capone he was
violent and extremely dangerous but he
was a different breed of monster
entirely this was the mad butcher of
kinsbury run
by the time eliot ness had accepted the
position of cleveland's new safety
director the city already had several
victims that had been murdered and
butchered with a knife but they were
being looked into as separate killings
the first major change that ness brought
to the table was to have the murders
investigated as the work of a single
killer an opinion that not everybody
shared at the time by the way we've got
a video on the butcher out already if
you want to get the in-depth picture of
that whole bloody shebang this section
won't be as detailed simply because ness
himself didn't really do that much it
wasn't like his chicago days when he was
in charge of a small team and always led
boots on the ground now he was a
director with hundreds of men under him
it was basically a desk job and less
spent his time signing papers to assign
manpower unfortunately vanessa's new gig
wasn't all it cracked up to be he was
hoping that he would get to do the
things he was good at such as conducting
raids and posing for photo ops whenever
his men busted down the doors of a
brothel or gambling den however the
butcher changed all of that once the
press got wind that murders were being
committed by a single madman stalking
the city that was the only story that
mattered ness had no choice but to focus
on that case and he was nowhere near as
successful as he was with capone for
what it's worth elliot ness always
believed he knew who the butcher was a
doctor named francis sweeney he just
couldn't prove it from 1938 on sweeney
began checking himself into various
mental institutions and maybe
coincidentally the murders also stopped
with no new leads and no more bodies the
investigation into the mad butcher of
kingsbury run slowly lost steam and
resources were reallocated to other
areas to give elliot ness is due he did
implement a lot of innovative ideas
during his time as safety director he
hired a traffic engineer who actually
won awards for how he reduced traffic
fatalities he introduced squad cars to
cleveland fitted with two-way radios so
police could respond faster to active
crimes he brought a scientific approach
to crime solving through the use of
ballistics and forensics eliot ness
thought that scientific policing was the
way of the future even before the fbi
had its own forensics lab he also used
undercover officers to weed out
corruption in the police ranks he also
created cleveland's first police academy
where cadets received physical and gun
training before being sent out on the
streets and last but certainly not least
he promoted crime prevention policies
such as community outreach programs and
vocational training aimed primarily at
children in crime-ridden areas in order
to stop them from joining gangs many of
nissa's ideas were later implemented in
other cities so he deserves credit for
modernizing the american police force
but unfortunately his inability to catch
the butcher permanently tainted his
reputation in cleveland in 1942 ness
resigned as safety director and accepted
a job as director of social protection
with the defense health agency
overseeing a program that promoted safe
sex and abstinence and tried to limit
the spread of venereal diseases which
was rampant on military bases during
world war ii after the war ness went
into private business for a while
running an import export operation and
serving as chairman of a lock and safe
company he dabbled in politics with
disastrous results running
unsuccessfully for mayor of cleveland in
1947 and using his own money during the
campaign by this time it'd become
evident that elliot ness's time with the
untouchables had been mostly forgotten
he was hurting financially he was
drinking heavily and he was on his third
marriage for a while it seemed like he
was destined to finish his days as a
washed-up has-been that none of us would
even remember today but one chance
meeting in 1955 changed all of that ness
crossed paths with oscar fraley a
popular sports writer of the day ten
years younger fraley had never even
heard of ness but he took an interest in
his stories of the good old days
fighting the mob and thought that the
rest of the world would be interested
too he persuaded ness to share his
account and together they wrote the
untouchables the memoir that cemented
elliot ness's place in the annals of
criminal history unfortunately for ness
he never got to see his name restored to
glory he died of a heart attack on may
16 1957 aged 54 just a few months before
the book came out
[Music]